bonjour et merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france
est ce qu'aujourd'hui la fréquentation
des lieux culturels et scientifiquement
liés en risque d'infection par le corps
d'un virus roger karoutchi a justement
toutes les études scientifiques que nous
avons il compris d'ailleurs un rapport
du mois de mars du conseil scientifique
national trouve qu' il n'y a aucun
élément permettant de dire qu'il y a par
exemple des clusters ou qui a eu des
clusters dans des salles de spectacle
que ce soit d'ailleurs des spectacles en
salle intérieure théâtre cinéma ou dans
des festivals extérieurs le jeu alors
qu'il reste fermé vous vous estimez que
c'est une décision arbitraire c'est pas
une décision arbitraire c'est une
décision
j'allais dire de prudence et une
décision un petit peu un petit peu de
protection parce que les autorités
nationales considère qu' évidemment
aller au théâtre
aller au cinéma ça nécessite se
retrouver entre amis en famille donc que
ça implique des regroupements des
rassemblements et je prends le sentiment
que c'est plus ça qui les inquiète que
la présence elle même dans les salles
c'est pour ça que nous nous avons fait
un certain nombre de propositions parce
que depuis le début du mois de janvier
le gouvernement n'arrête pas de dire
nous allons réouvrir les lieux de
culture puisque on considère qu'ils sont
essentiels dans la vie sociale mais pour
le moment on n'a rien vu venir
donc on a présenté un certain nombre de
propositions sur les jauges sur les
protocoles sanitaires sur le déroulé
possible des réouvertures partie
commence-t-on notre position c'est de
commencer par les musées les théâtres
les cinémas
parce que dans ces lieux clos on peut
plus facilement déterminer des
protocoles sanitaires déterminer des
jauges déterminer des cheminements faire
en sorte qu'il n'y ait pas de
possibilité de boire ou manger
donc ça veut dire pas de pop corn et pas
d'esquimaux mais seul avantage c'est que
ça veut dire musées théâtres cinémas
vous gardez vos masques
ici vous gardez les masques si on
maintient la distance
s'il ya des cheminements il n'y a aucune
raison d'avoir des contaminations et
donc des clusters et ça permettrait dès
la mi mai surtout si comme nous le
proposons le gouvernement aide à prendre
des mesures d équipements de ventilation
et d'aération supplémentaires sur toutes
les salles nous pourrions ré ouvrir
progressivement théâtres cinémas musées
dès la mi mai en disant plutôt confiance
aux élus locaux et à la préfecture
plutôt qu'à l'état central pourquoi
c'est pas du tout de notre part une
inquiétude par rapport à l'état son
talent mais c'est que chacun comprend
bien que vous avez des théâtres certains
sont 2000 places et d'autres sons et
théâtre de poche
vous avez de très grandes salles où on
peut facilement mettre des jauges
inférieur être des cheminements mettre
de la distance que vous avez de toute
petite salle de théâtre ou et bâle aéré
où ces conditions ne peuvent pas être
rempli donc plutôt que de dire on ouvre
tout tous les cinémas tous les théâtres
tous les musées en même temps nous nous
disons préparons l'ouverture par des
propositions des élus locaux des
communes avec l'accord des préfets de
manière puisque chaque commune sait très
bien ce que représente son théâtre et
cinéma ses mulets et à partir de là
réouvre on part tous messages sanitaires
que vous évoquez à l'instant est ce que
les lieux culturels ne sont pas déjà en
capacité de les mettre en place et de
rouvrir bien avant
ni mais alors il alors il ya un premier
élément c'est que naturellement pendant
les ça comme vous voulez le pseudo
confinement ou le confinement
d'aujourd'hui qui va de toute manière
normalement normalement s'il n'est pas
prolongé jusqu'au 3 mai en tout état de
cause ces lieux ne peuvent pas ouvrir
pour le moment donc l'ouverture la plus
tôt possible soit être début mai nous
nous proposons que ce soit vers la
mi-mai parce que les protocoles sont pas
près partout mais pour les cinémas et
les théâtres sont quasiment prêts nous
pouvons avoir de la part de l'état une
action un peu volontaire sur la
ventilation à laquelle les scientifiques
tiennent beaucoup ce qui permettrait
d'ouvrir
sinon d'un coup du moins progressivement
de tous les éléments à partir de la mi
mai dans l'opposition nous maintenons
quand même des aides publiques pour
assortir en siffler si je puis dire
serait à réduire progressivement n'eut
pas d'un coup parce que le personne ne
s'illusionne si vous ré ouvre et tous
étaient appelés cinéma les musées à la
mi mai il va pas y avoir d'un coup
participation énorme parce qu' un
certain nombre de citoyens vont visiter
et comme on aura mis des jauges
inférieur à la capacité habituelle
forcément l' équilibre financier ne sera
pas forcément à terme tout de suite en
tout cas dans les premières semaines
peuvent pour les places ces protocoles
sanitaires six mois roger karoutchi ça
semble une éternité comme on compte dans
d'autres pays
je suis bien d'accord l'espagne
l'espagne qui depuis plusieurs mois déjà
pratique des expérimentations notamment
sur ses concerts test pourquoi est-ce
que rien de tel n'est fait en france
alors il devait y avoir un concert tests
en france fin mars et un concert test
enfants 9 avril
évidemment on est tombé dans la période
de reconfirmer donc les deux concerts
tests n'ont pas lieu ils sont en tout
cas pour l'un des deux reporter de me
dire sur vers le 20 mai et a fait de
manière sûre en tout cas programmée vers
le bas mais nous aurons à ce moment là
des retours lors sur les concerts comme
sur les festivals c'est à dire sur des
éléments plus lourds plus important avec
beaucoup plus de participants
que les théâtres cinémas musées là nous
préconisons un certain nombre de
dispositifs avec pour nous l'obligation
de dire attention par exemple les
festivals à 5000 personnes qu'ils soient
assis ou debout
il faut qu'on ait un pass à lithaire
paulo le pass and i ter n'est pas le
pass vaccinale que vous ne pouvez pas
imposer aujourd'hui tant que la
vaccination n'est pas plus importante
que ce qu'elle n'est évident que tant
que vous n'avez que 10 ou 15% de la
population vaccinée
cette illusoire d'imposer le pass
vaccinale ma revanche
on dit pas sanitaire ce qui comprend
pour ceux qui sont vaccinées le
certificat vaccinale pour ce qu'ils ne
sont pas l'obligation d'un test pcr
avant d'accéder au festival au grand
concert était là mais il faut ré ouvrir
ce qui veut dire aussi d'ailleurs que
pour les festivals comme pour les
concerts pour éviter que tous les
festivals le choix nul et on a déjà vu
l'annulation des eurockéennes
l'annulation du festival d'angoulême
si on veut éviter ça notre proposition
c'est que très vite et en jeu ni très
vite c'est maintenant que l'état se
porte garant pour l'organisation des
festivals pourquoi est ce que les
festivals annuler les uns après les
autres
c'est qu'évidemment la programmation les
contrats avec les artistes les contrats
avec les fournisseurs
si ensuite on leur dit que le festival
n'a pas lieu c'est une perte sèche
considérable donc il faut que l'état
s'engage à être la garantie de manière à
ce que ces festivals puisse s'engager et
prendre le moins de risques financiers
possibles si on veut qu'il se perpétuent
les années suivantes toutes les
atteintes ou dernier mot si vous le
voulez bien roger karoutchi parce que
malheureusement le temps nous manque six
mois de fermeture de l'ensemble des
lieux culturels en france visiblement ce
n'est pas la priorité
du gouvernement on est loin aujourd'hui
de l'exception culturelle française
c'est une expression dépassé aujourd'hui
à la leo tavannes oui c'est une
exception culturelle celle de la
fermeture parce que nos voisins italiens
suisses espagnols on verra alors pas
toujours avec de grands succès en italie
sont ouverts fermé ou ouvert fermé mais
en france la l'espèce de règles
centralisatrice qui fait que toutes les
régions y compris celles qui étaient le
moins touché par la pandémie
voyez tous leurs lieux de culture fermé
est une aberration il est évident que si
comme le dit le président l'a public on
doit vivre avec le virus
il faut aussi faire en sorte que
localement les autorités locales les
préfectures puisse dire on a un
protocole sanitaire
on peut ouvrir on a dans notre région
dans notre secteur une pandémie très
faible avec 1 porto cole sanitaires les
mesures de distanciation on tour est un
peu plus de pragmatisme
un peu plus de confiance dans les élus
locaux et les lieux de culture peuvent
réouvrir en tout cas en protégeant la
population
merci beaucoup d'avoir accepté notre
invitation sur rt france roger karoutchi
sénateur les républicains en des
hauts-de-seine et co-rapporteur donc de
cette admission d'informations sur les
effets des mesures sanitaires